-The January 6th hearings
have provided a mountain
of new evidence
about the relentless,
all-encompassing plan
by Donald Trump and his cronies
to overturn the 2020 election,
but maybe the biggest
revelation, so far,
has been the degree to which the
people involved in the scheme
all had criminal intent
and knew what they were doing
was against the law.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Look, I'm not especially hopeful
that the January 6th hearings
are going to magically
change the minds
of any hardcore Trump fans
in the Republican Party.
I mean, I hope they do,
but we've been
through a seven-year-long
onslaught of Trump scandals,
including two impeachments;
a violent coup;
and a sex scandal,
in which he paid hush money,
during a presidential campaign,
to cover up an affair
with a porn star
and lied about it,
up until the point
where the actual check
he personally wrote
to make the payment surfaced
with his signature on it.
[ Laughter ]
And the way you know
that's Donald Trump signature is
that he looks like he signed it
with a giant Sharpie
while he was
white water rafting.
[ Laughter ]
Remember that whole thing?
Looking back now,
I have to say I always imagined
hush money
would be paid
in a more covert way
than writing
and signing a check.
That was more like yell money.
[ Laughter ]
I just assumed, from movies,
it would be an envelope full
of unmarked bills
passed between parked cars
down at the docks.
I never would've imagined
Trump sitting down
to balance his checkbook,
going through all
the hush money payments.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Alright, let's see.
$150 for the cable bill.
That's fair.
I watch a lot of cable.
[ Laughter ]
$300 for groceries.
Eat a lot of groceries.
Let's see, $130,000
to adult film star
to cover up sex scandal.
More than fair.
[ Laughter ]
Mel!
Mel, honey, do you have
any hush money payments
you need me to make?
[ Laughter ]
No, because I'm doing the bill
and, if you have hush money,
I'd love to --
Why? Because I don't want
to pay late fees.
[ Laughter ]
Mel, I don't want to be
the only frugal one
in this relationship, Mel.
None of that really seemed
to move the needle
with Republicans,
so I'm not optimistic
the January 6th hearings
are going to seriously
influence the GOP.
But I am hopeful the hearings
will influence
prosecutors
in the Justice Department
because one area
where these hearings
have been shockingly successful
has been establishing
criminal intent
and a consciousness of guilt
among Trump and his gang
of pro-coup weirdos,
as they were planning
and orchestrating the coup.
Take disgraced former national
security advisor Michael Flynn,
who participated in discussions
where, among other things,
he pushed Trump
to use the military
to seize voting machines.
Flynn invoked
the Fifth Amendment
during a series
of what you would think
would be pretty
straightforward questions,
for any nonfascists.
-Do you believe the violence
on January 6th
was justified morally?
[ Laughter ]
-You believe the violence
on January 6th
was justified legally?
General Flynn, do you believe
in the peaceful transition
of power
in the United States of America?
[ Laughter ]
You're pleading the Fifth
over a hypothetical that has
nothing to do with the law?
The Fifth Amendment
doesn't work like that.
It's not "Family Feud."
It doesn't say...
[ Laughter ]
It protects you
from self-incrimination.
And, look,
I'm generally very opposed
to drawing conclusions
about someone's guilt,
just because they
plead the Fifth.
It's a constitutional right
and it's in there for a reason.
These are just
benign hypotheticals.
This is like
if your spouse said,
"How do you feel
about monogamy?"
And your answer was,
"I'm invoking
my Fifth Amendment right not
to answer
any questions
about your sister."
[ Laughter ]
It's not going to end
the conversation.
That's how aware these guys were
that they were in legal trouble.
They wouldn't even
answer questions
about whether they believe
in the peaceful transfer
of power.
In fact, at almost every turn,
key White House officials
made it very clear
that they knew they were
in significant legal jeopardy.
For example, on Tuesday,
former Trump White House
official Cassidy Hutchinson
recounted, in a damning comment
from Trump's White House
counsel Pat Violoncello,
after he found out
that Trump wanted
to go to the Capitol himself
and lead the armed mob
in overthrowing
the election results.
-We understand,
Ms. Hutchinson,
that you also spoke
to Mr. Cipollone
on the morning of the 6th,
as you were about to go
to the rally on the Ellipse,
and Mr. Cipollone said
something to you like,
"Make sure the movement
to the Capitol does not happen."
Is that correct?
-That's correct.
I saw Mr. Cipollone
right before I walked out
onto West Exec that morning
and Mr. Cipollone said something
to the effect of,
"Please make sure we don't go
up to the Capitol, Cassidy.
Keep in touch with me.
We're going to get charged
with every crime imaginable,
if we make
that movement happen."
-And do you remember
which crimes
Mr. Cipollone
was concerned with?
-In the days leading
up to the 6th,
we had conversations
about potentially
obstructing justice
or defrauding
the electoral count.
-It's amazing.
"We're going to get charged
with every crime imaginable."
It's truly mind-boggling to me
that none of these guys are
in jail, yet,
when they themselves were
expecting to end up in jail.
Merrick Garland's still poring
over transcripts,
looking for a smoking gun.
Meanwhile, on January 6th,
Trump aides were all
on Pinterest, searching for...
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, cool!
It says you can bedazzle
your handcuffs!"
And, crucially,
that comment from Cipollone
was not just a one-time
freak-out on January 6th.
As Hutchinson made clear
in that clip,
there were conversations
even before January 6th
about the likelihood that
Trump aides were committing,
among other crimes,
obstruction of justice
or defrauding
the electoral count.
Think about that.
They even named
the specific laws
they were breaking.
They literally laid out
a blueprint
for prosecutors to arrest them.
I mean, how much easier
can you make it?
This is like if, on every page,
Waldo was holding up
a giant sign that said...
[ Laughter ]
That was not the only time
a White House lawyer
warned Trump cronies
that they were breaking the law.
For example,
there was also Eric Herschmann,
whose job, it seems like,
was basically to tell everyone
in the Trump White House
they were constantly
breaking the law.
Now, you might
remember Herschmann
from previous hearings,
as the guy
who has a baseball bat with the
word justice written on it
[ Laughter ]
hanging on his wall.
I like that it's not mounted
on wood
or in a glass case or anything.
It's just right there on hooks
at grabbing height.
[ Laughter ]
I bet, when people
got their lunches out of the
office fridge at his firm,
they triple-checked
they had the bag right.
[ Laughter ]
Herschmann was in a meeting
with another key figure
in the attempted coup --
Justice Department
official Jeffrey Clark.
Clark wanted Trump to make him
attorney general
after the election,
so that, as attorney general,
Clark could declare,
without evidence,
that there was fraud
in the election
and then overturn the results.
And Herschmann had very blunt
words for Clark
when he found out
about Clark's plan.
-When he finished discussing
what he planned on doing,
I said, "Good [bleep]."
Excuse me. Sorry.
"Effing a-hole,
congratulations,
you just admitted the first step
or act you'd take
as attorney general
would be committing a felony."
-I like that the guy
has enough decorum
not to curse in a deposition,
but still keeps a baseball bat
in the frame,
[ Laughter ]
just to keep everyone on edge.
I wish I could've been
a fly on the wall
for all his conversations
in the White House.
[ As Herschmann ]
If you break the law, I'm going
to use this baseball bat
and beat the living [bleep]
out of you.
Sorry!
The living eff out of you.
[ Laughter ]
Please,
please excuse
my horrible manners,
you dumb [bleep] piece
of [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
So, yet again, we have
a Trump White House official
making it plain as day that
the people planning the coup
knew they were breaking the law
when they were doing it.
For example, we also know,
from testimony given
by a former aide to Mike Pence,
that John Eastman,
the pro-coup lawyer
who wrote the memo
detailing how Pence was supposed
to overturn the results
on January 6th,
also knew his plan was illegal.
Eastman admitted, in the
Oval Office, in front of Trump,
that his plan would violate
the Electoral Count Act
and, after the whole thing
descended
into violence and chaos
on the 6th,
Herschmann --
the baseball bat guy --
[ Laughter ]
again offered a very stark
warning to Eastman.
I screamed...
-[ Laughs ]
-And I screamed --
[ Laughter ]
-Man, where did this guy
get his law degree?
Does Yale Law School have
a building on campus called...
[ Laughter ]
The only problem with that
library -- it's great,
but as soon as you learn
something there,
you fuhgeddaboudit.
[ Laughter ]
And, as we've also discovered,
from these hearings,
Trump's cronies had such
a clear consciousness of guilt
that a lot of them were asking
for preemptive pardons.
They knew they could be
prosecuted and they wanted Trump
to get them off the hook
before that happened.
-Dr. Eastman emailed
Rudy Giuliani
and requested that he be
included on a list
of potential recipients
of a presidential pardon.
-Did Rudy Giuliani ever suggest
that he was interested
in receiving a presidential
pardon related to January 6th?
-He did.
-Ms. Hutchison, did White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
ever indicate
that he was interested
in receiving a presidential
pardon related to January 6th?
-Mr. Meadows did seek
that pardon, yes, ma'am.
[ Laughter ]
-At this point,
it's easier to ask
who wasn't looking for a pardon.
[ Laughter ]
Mr. President, here's a list
of the people
who want pardons...
[ Laughter ]
and that kid who mow the lawn.
Do you remember him?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he needs a pardon.
I guess he maybe stole
that lawnmower.
[ Laughter ]
I just love the fact
that Matt Gaetz was just
going around,
telling people he asked
for a pardon,
like it was cool
and not incriminating.
Although, Gaetz does seem
like a guy who doesn't know
what he says makes him look bad.
[ As Gaetz ]
Hey, Jeff was saying cold water
makes his ween look small,
but I was like, "Dude,
mine looks small, no matter
what temperature the water is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Am I right? Am I right?
Herschmann, am I right?"
[ As Herschmann ]
Shut the [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
Shut the eff up.
These hearings have sent
a clear message
to prosecutors
in the Justice Department.
Not only is there sufficient
evidence to charge Trump
and his cronies
with multiple crimes,
there's also sufficient evidence
that they were aware
they were potentially
committing crimes at the time
that they were orchestrating
the attempted coup.
If you're, say,
a Republican or Trump supporter
watching these hearings
and you come to the conclusion
that everything these guys did
was legal and aboveboard,
then I'm sorry, you're a...
-Excuse me. Sorry.
"Effing a-hole."
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.